في حياه الناس تراه
للقتال اثر بالغ في واقعهم المعيشي واضح
ان الارقام المتلاحقه عن التداعيات
الانسانيه من مواجهات المسلحه في السودان
حفزت جهدا اكبر للمجتمع الدولي
هكذا تعلن الامم المتحده عن حزمه مساعدات
للسودان قيمتها 200 مليون دولار
للمساعدات الانسانيه في السودان وتبلغ
مليارا وسبعه مئه مليون دولار لتغطيه
الحاجات الاساسيه من المواد الغذائيه
والاساسيه وكل ما نتوقع ان يحتاجه السكان
في دارفور تمكنا حتى الان من جمع 200
مليون دولار من احتياجات هذا العام والان
نحن بحاجه الى المزيد من الاموال بسبب
تدعيه النزاع خلال الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه لكن ثمه حاجه اولا لموافقه طرفي
النزاع في السودان حتى يتم ادخال
المساعدات
ابلغت الطرفين قبولي التوجه الى اي مكان
في السودان للقائهما او لقاء ما ينوب
عنهما للتباحث بشان التزامات يجب على
الطرفين قبولها واهمها تعهدهما بضروره
السماح بايصال المساعدات للشعب السوداني
كلا الجنرانين ابديا استعدادا لتقديم مثل
هذه التعهدات ونحن الان في خضم التباحث
بشان اليات عقد الاجتماعين مع الطرفين
يشدد مارتن على التزام الامم المتحده تجاه
الشعب السوداني ولا يفوته التعبير عن
تقديره لجهود المتطوعين والعاملين في
المجال الانساني
هذا مجال دونه معوقات كبيره وان خصصت له
موارد ماليه
طبيعي ان تسعى المنظمه الدوليه لاخذ
ضمانات من جميع الاطراف بحمايه موظفيها
ووصول المساعدات الانسانيه
لكن مع استمرار المعارك قد يتعطل ذلك
المسعى او تبطئ وتييرته وقد تطول جراء ذلك
معاناه قطاعات حيويه في السودان القى
الاقتتال بظلال قاتمه عليها
نقابه اطباء السودان اعلنت خروج 61 مستشفى
من الخدمه في الخرطوم وحدها بسبب القتال
انها منظومه السودان الصحيه المشارفه على
الانهيار بفعل قصف المشافي ونفادي الادويه
وقبل الدواء تمت الغذاء فالى ما يمضي
الحال بالسودان وثلث سكانه كانوا قبل
اندلاع القتال يعتمدون في الاساس على
المساعدات الغذائيه
في جوانب الازمه الاخرى شح المياه ومشتقات
الوقود والقطاعات خدمات الكهرباء بلغ
الضرر قطاع التعليم مع اغلاق عشرات
الجامعات والاف المدارس في مناطق تتركز
فيها المواجهات المسلحه اما في الجانب
الاقتصادي فقد نظرت السيوله النقديه بفعل
نهب مصارف وتوقف معظمها عن العمل
لا تخفي الامم المتحده الحاجه لنحو مليار
ونصف المليار دولار خلال العام الحالي
وحده في شكل مساعدات انسانيه لملايين
السودانيين يشمل ذلك من علق منهم في مناطق
القتال وكذا مئات الالوف ممن توزعت
مصائرهم بين نازح محليا وطالب لجوء وراء
الحدود